Susan I had been friends for years and
Susan is one of the funniest people I
know she's a comedian but it sort of
began with conversations that we had
about stupid things that we had done
while we were drunk sort of trying to
one-up each other and Susan's stories
sort of Eclipse mine by mile and and we
you know Susan got sober in our early
20s and you know we at a certain point
talked about our sort of mutual desire
to tell a story there was a love story
and a coming-of-age story that dealt
with alcoholism but that was not about
alcoholism something that was not a
social issue movie that was not a scared
straight film something that really
spoke to us you know and something that
very definitely had a female protagonist
with young characters and where there
was real humor yeah and we had talked a
lot about you know something that we
could relate to or that our generation
could relate to and to make you know
alcoholism not seem like a creepy
horrible thing but something that is
very human and it's just a human flaw
and like you know that that all people
have their flaws and this happens to be
you know Kate's and we we didn't want to
make it a monster or a movie about other
nests we wanted Kate to be somebody that
we could relate to and you know somebody
that that young women would say like oh
i know that girl or maybe i am that girl
most the cast was assembled sort of last
minute so we didn't really have any
traditional rehearsals or anything like
that at most you know Octavia and I most
the cast didn't meet until we were on
set doing our scenes together Aaron Paul
and I had one night out together to try
and get to know each other and have some
drinks and then sort of form a bond and
so we did the karaoke involved no I
think wait I think there was some
singing but no karaoke but yet even that
was just a very brief you know day that
we had together so so yeah there wasn't
a lot of time on that front but James
and I spent a lot of you know weeks
together really figuring out who kate is
and trying to to craft that character I
was cast before the help ever came out
and was a success or anything
oh no and I was so thrilled because you
know they're there was a point where I
was like oh my god I'm a little bit
nervous I don't know what I'm going to
do next and yeah you know you think
you're supposed to have that at some
point and when I got the call about my
agent read the script and said you have
to do this little movie and when I read
it and then I heard the people that were
involved i said well tell me what to do
who do i call and james and i met and it
was just his mitt so I was thrilled well
I have never had the type of career Lord
that I have right now and I'm so
grateful Academy Wow um you know that
there aren't a lot of rolls out there
for women and definitely voluptuous
women like myself but what the Academy
Award has afforded me is the opportunity
to know what's out there and to go into
rooms and you know say you know I think
I might want to play a superhero one day
and people not laughs you know but so
you've been doing mostly independent
I've done mostly independence and since
the Academy Awards and I'm thrilled
because they are more challenging and
it's just been exciting I it's been
exciting it's been a career changer and
the best way possible I was very
fortunate to be able to you know cast
the film with some of my favorite actors
people who can handle comedy and drama
and are just the type of people that you
whether they're in it for a scene or
whether they're carrying the movie you
want to spend so much time with them but
I you know it started with Mary erin was
the next one that we cast and i just
love aaron from breaking bad as we're
writing the script I tried not to
picture any actor in any of the rules
but I kept picturing Aaron and I was
like we'll never get Aaron Paul but um
but that's why I pictured and if that's
any testament to the secret
James I have to tell you this you met my
friend Kelly and she basically is going
through you know their situation with
with an alcoholic in her family and she
said to me that house is so exact
because people start you know not paying
attention to fixing it up and throwing
up a you know a sheet somewhere it was
just really interesting like the the eye
for detail that I just thought oh that's
a cute little you know the eye for
detail so hearing it from someone who's
actually living it was I've never quite
been part of such a collaborative
process before and doing a film and just
working with James and everyone involved
in the film you know everyone's ideas
and thoughts were important and added
something to the end result and it just
felt like we were all in it as a family
which was very meaningful to me it
wasn't like do as you're told say your
lines fit into this box just make us
happy it was bring something to it show
me something that I hadn't already
thought of and so that just having
people put that kind of trust in me was
liberating and just opened up so much in
me